[Music]  foreign virus coverage today at noon and  concern about the  delta variant that was first discovered  in india cdc says that strain now  accounts for 20 percent of all new covet  cases here in the u.s  government health officials say the  delta variant spreads very easily  especially among people who are not  vaccinated and it could become the  dominant strain  in the u.s right now it's about 20.6  percent  in the united states and doubles about  every two weeks  so the easiest way to stop this is to  get vaccinated because fortunately for  us  the vaccine works quite well against it  well health officials also say while the  vaccine does work well now  they can't guarantee it will be as  effective against that new strain or any  future  new strains